In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon for June 11, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostles
Bartholomew and Barnabas.
The Holy Apostle Bartholomew whom some identify with Nathaniel, an Israelite without Gael
who was the first to confess the Son of God was from Cana in Galilee.
He was numbered among the twelve Apostles who followed Christ right to his Passion and
were witnesses of his Resurrection.
After Pentecost when the Apostles drew lots for the parts of the world that it would fall
to them to evangelize, he was chosen to go to proclaim the good news in Arabia Felix,
now North Yemen.
He first went in company with the Apostle Philip and his sister, Mariamna, to evangelize
the regions of Lydia and Mizia in Asia Minor.
They were arrested and yetopolis in Frigia and crucified head downwards, but when Philip
gave up the ghost, the earth opened and swallowed up a great many of the pagans.
The survivors in terror took Bartholomew and Mariamna down from their crosses.
Bartholomew established stockies as Bishop of the town and continued his missionary journeys
enduring hunger, cold, danger on the roads, persecution and imprisonment with constancy.
He brought the light of truth to a great many pagans in Arabia, Persia and India and left
them the gospel according to Saint Matthew, written in Aramaic, which Pantenos of Alexandria
found a century later.
He then went to Armenia where he finished his course, crucified as his master was, or according
to others, flayed alive in Albanopolis, on the orders of King Astragis, whose son he had
converted and whose daughter he had delivered from a demon.
The apostles' body was then placed in an iron coffin and thrown into the sea, but through
God's intervention, instead of sinking down into the depths, the sarcophagus floated
to the island of Liebadi, in Sicily, where his relics worked many miracles.
Saint Barnabas was a Cyprus-born Levite and had probably been instructed in the law
by Gamaliel.
He was living in Jerusalem at the time the first Christian community was being formed, and
seeing how the faithful who were gathered around the apostles had one heart and one mind and
held all things in common, he sold the field that he possessed and came to place the money
at the apostles' feet.
From that time on he lived from the work of his hands like Saint Paul, a good man, full
of the Holy Spirit, and of faith, he had been given the word of exhortation and encouragement,
and the apostles therefore changed his name from Joseph to Barnabas, son of consolation.
Three years after his conversion, Saint Paul, fleeing from Damascus, arrived in Jerusalem
where everyone was afraid of him, thinking that he was feigning belief in order to arrest
them.
Barnabas then took Paul with him and told them how Christ had appeared to him, and the assurance
with which he preached in Damascus at peril of his life.
And then on they became friends and fellow-workers in the apostolic labors.
Paul, however, encountered further obstacles and had to leave for Tarsus.
At the same time the news having reached Jerusalem that a great many pagans had been converted
in Antioch, the apostles deputed Barnabas to go and see what was happening.
He rejoiced greatly to see the grace that God had given them and encouraged the new converts
to live with one heart, firmly faithful to the Lord.
He then went to seek Paul in Tarsus, and they spent a whole year confirming the church
in Antioch, where, for the first time, the name Christian was used.
And some of the faithful from Jerusalem having the gift of prophecy arrived in Antioch
and announced that a great famine would soon cover the world.
The Christians of Antioch, better provided for, made a collection and gave it to Paul and
Barnabas to take to their brethren in Jerusalem.
This mission accomplished they returned to Antioch, taking with them John, called Mark.
This is cousin.
One day, when they were celebrating the Lord's service and were fasting, the Holy Spirit
said, separate me, Barnabas, and Saul, for the work where Antioch, I have called them.
After having received the prayers and good wishes of the faithful, the two apostles, guided
by the Holy Spirit, then left on their mission, taking Mark with them.
They embarked for Salusia.
Once they set sail for Cyprus, disembarking at Salamina, the chief town, they immediately
preached the word of God in the Jewish synagogues.
They then went on to Paphos, at the furthest extremity of the island, where the Roman Pro-Consul,
Sergius Paulus, lived, and he summoned them to instruct him in their doctrine.
However, a Jewish magician called Bargesus, whom the magistrate had by him to advise him,
attempted to deflect the interest he was showing in the apostles, but, at a word from Paul,
he was struck with blindness, and the Pro-Consul embraced the faith.
From Paphos, the missionaries then reached Perga in Pamphilia, and went on thence to Pesidian
Antioch.
There, they went to the synagogue on the Sabbath day, and Paul preached with such success
that the following week almost the whole town gathered to hear the word of God.
When the Jews, filled with jealousy, reacted to Paul's words with blasphemy, the apostles
replied, it was necessary that the word of God should first have been spoken to you.
But seeing you put it from you, and judge yourselves worthy of everlasting life, low,
we are turning to the Gentiles.
The Gentiles exalted with joy at this news, and the word of God spread throughout the region,
but the Jews incited a persecution of the two apostles and succeeded in driving them away.
They then went to Iconium, where a great crowd of Jews and Gentiles was converted, but
there again the Calus Jews provoked an uprising against them.
As they were preparing to stone them, they left for Lyconia and proclaimed the good news in
Lystra, Derb, and the surrounding area.
In Lystra, Paul, having healed a man crippled from birth, the pagans wanted to honor them
as incarnations of gods, and calling Barnabas Zeus and Paul Hermes, they prepared to
offer them sacrifice.
The Apostle had only just succeeded in preventing this, when Jews from Antioch and Iconium swayed
the crowd and managed to have the Apostles stoned.
Paul barely escaped death by the intervention of his disciples, and finding Barnabas they
took ship for Derb.
After having preached the Gospel in this town, they returned, scorning the danger, to Lystra,
Iconium, and Pesidian Antioch, to encourage the new believers to persevere in their trials.
There they appointed elders, presbyters, for each church and organized the Christian life.
During then through Pesidia and Pamphilia, and spending some time in Perga, they set sail
at Atalia for Antioch, their point of departure, where they gave the faithful an account of all
that God had done through them, and how they had opened the door of the faith to the pagans
of Asia Minor.
They stayed some time in Antioch until they had to leave for Jerusalem to join the Apostles
and elders in settling the dispute that had arisen concerning the necessity of imposing
circumcision on Christians who had come from paganism.
They were welcomed by the church of Jerusalem and told the signs and wonders that God had accomplished
with the pagans.
This testimony, being heard by the assembly of Apostles and elders, with Saint James who
spoke in their favor, presiding, it was decided not to worry the newly converted with the
obsolete precepts of the old covenant, but only to ask them to abstain from food, offered
to idols, illegitimate unions, from things strangled and from blood, in order not to scandalize
the faithful of Jewish birth.
The Council of Jerusalem then sent Paul and Barnabas on their way, accompanied by Jude
and Silas, giving them a letter, telling the church of Antioch of their decision inspired
by the Holy Spirit.
When the Antioch faithful read the letter, they rejoiced greatly, and after Jude and Silas
had left, Paul and Barnabas continued teaching them.
Two years later, around 51, Saint Paul suggested to Barnabas that they undertake a new journey
in the regions they had evangelized, but refused to take Mark with them, as he had left them
during their previous mission.
The discussion became heated, and they ended up going their separate ways, without, however,
breaking the bond of charity.
Barnabas set sail for Cyprus, in company with Mark, while Paul took Silas with him and
departed for new adventures.
Landing at Salamina, Barnabas resumed his preaching with zeal, and made numerous conversions until
the day that the Jews who had come from Syria spread rumors that Barnabas was preaching lies.
Being learned of this plot and being warned of what was to come, the Holy Apostle celebrated
the divine liturgy, and then, taking Mark aside, told him of his coming death, indicating
the place where he should be buried, and telling him to go and give the news to Saint Paul.
He then went to the synagogue and proclaimed with words of fire that Jesus is indeed the
son of the living God.
Grinding their teeth, the Jews from Syria seized hold of him and shut him in a dark place.
That same evening, they took him out to drag him out of the town, where they stoned him,
as Saint Stephen, the proto-marter, had been, and then threw his body into a brazier.
But it was preserved by the grace of God, and Mark was able to give him decent burial.
After this, he went to Ephesus, where he told Paul about Barnabas' martyrdom.
During the reign of Emperor Zeno in 488, the Holy Apostle Barnabas appeared in a vision to
Anthemius, Bishop of Salamina, and revealed to him the place where his body was concealed.
The bishop went there at once, and found in the cave indicated by the saint, the coffin,
containing his intact body, on the chest of which lay a copy in Greek of the Gospel according
to Saint Matthew, which the Apostle had copied with his own hand.
Thanks to this miracle which showed the apostolic origin of the Church of Cyprus, it was able
to obtain from the Emperor the confirmation of its independence, which, till then, had been
contested by the Church of Antioch.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.